اليوم يتطوع لويس كولون وهيلدا روميرو
للإجابة على الأسئلة المتعلقة
باختبار الخرف وهما جاهزان لإجراء بعض الاختبارات
اليوم تكشف إجاباتهما الكثير عن
الذاكرة وكيف يمكن أن تسوء الأمور الخرف
هو مرض يصيب واحدًا من كل 10
أمريكيين من كبار السن أريد منكم أن تأخذوه
قلم الرصاص وارسم خطًا من رقم
إلى آخر بالترتيب
حسنًا،
نحن نجري هذا الاختبار لربط الأرقام
بأسرع ما يمكن لأنه يخبرنا
بمدى سهولة التركيز على إكمال
مهمة بسيطة نسبيًا ومدى السرعة التي
يمكنه بها القيام بذلك بشكل جيد  هل يمكنك نسخ هذا
التصميم في المساحة هنا؟ نحن نختبر كلاً من
الذاكرة اللفظية والذاكرة البصرية لأنهما
موجودان في أجزاء مختلفة من
الدماغ وعندما نطلب من شخص ما أن
يرسم صورة، فإننا لا نختبر
ذاكرته البصرية فحسب، بل نختبر قدرته على ذلك  قم
بتنظيم المعلومات على قطعة من الورق،
حسنًا لتفسير الإجابات بشكل صحيح،
سيحتاج الأطباء إلى معرفة
التاريخ الطبي للمريض ومنذ متى
بدأوا في ملاحظة التغييرات، بعض الأشخاص
ينسون فقط ولكن هناك
فرق كبير مع الخرف، لذا
قد يكون النسيان الطبيعي شيئًا من هذا القبيل  لقد
نسيت مفاتيحي ولكن لا ينبغي على
سبيل المثال أن تنسى أسماء
أفراد العائلة أو
التواريخ المهمة في حياتك، لذا فإن الوقت الذي
نشعر بالقلق حقًا هو عندما
يحدث ذلك بانتظام، لذا فإن وجود نمط من
الخرف سيكون أسهل كثيرًا  إذا
كانت الذاكرة فقط، فإن قدرتنا على
التركيز حقًا على شيء ما يمكن أن تتلاشى، بعض الأشخاص
يصابون بتغيرات في المزاج، الخرف هو
مرض يتطور، لذا في
النهاية لا يمكنك المشي، لا يمكنك إطعام
نفسك، لا يمكنك البلع،
والسبب في ذلك  قد ترغب في التحقق من ذلك
مع الطبيب، لأن هناك
أشياء يمكن أن تبدو مثل الخرف
ولكنها ليست كذلك وقد تكون قابلة للعلاج.
يوضح السؤال التالي مدى صعوبة
اكتشاف الخرف، لذا سأقدم لك
قائمة بالكلمات  أريدك أن تستمع
بعناية ثم تكررها
لي مرة أخرى، لنرى كم من الوقت يستغرق الشخص
لتعلم نوع من القائمة الطويلة من الكلمات،
ثم نرى كم عدد الكلمات التي يمكنه تذكرها
لاحقًا ثم شخص مصاب بالخرف
قد يتمكن من تعلمها  الكلمات ولكن عندما
تعود بعد نصف ساعة، فإنهم
حقًا لا يستطيعون تذكر أي منها تقريبًا وذلك
عندما نعرف أن هناك شيئًا
غير طبيعي الآن هل تتذكر
الكلمات الأربع التي أخبرتك بها قبل المدرسة هيلدا
الزرقاء تتذكر الكلمات في
الواقع يا دكتور  قال إن كلا المتطوعين قاما بعمل
جيد في الاختبار التجريبي والآن أود
منكم ضبط الوقت على الساعة 10:11. إذا كان
شخص ما يحتاج إلى مزيد من التقييم، فعليه إجراء
ما نسميه
الاختبار النفسي العصبي، شكرًا لك،
قد يشعر الناس بالخوف من ذلك ولكن أكثر من ذلك  في
كثير من الأحيان، يستمتع الناس
كثيرًا بإجراء هذه الاختبارات، وأنا
أتطلع إلى ذلك، إنه عصر الشيطان في دبي